my shopping guide to buying the best
hams salamis and sausages
these fine italian meats are packed with
flavor and a little goes a long way
and nobody knows that better than deli
maestro antonio
born in italy and start eating italian
food
and i love it i want to change it for
nothing else
that's why i'm fat
he's been selling delicious cured meats
in the heart of london soho for more
than 35 years
this is the best prosciutto
they come from italy this is curing
parma
because it's parma ham divine
people love it and it's wonderful the
fat is good because you make the
meat sweet this should be cut thin like
this
there is more flavor you can eat with
melon with figs with pears with
everything
any sweet fruit is good
it's wonderful you really enjoy when you
start eating
you can stop wonderful this is called
prisaola
it's a hair cured beef come from uh
north italy voltelina is so different
from
pork there's no fat at all it should be
no fun otherwise it tastes greasy it's
good
when it's very dry and you slice it
thinner you
just eat it like that or you can eat
with a bit of rocket
or you shave some parmesan on top i love
it
a bit of lemon if you like or olive oil
it's delicious this is called
felino for me is the best salami
take the name for a little place near
parma
and other is country salami
very nice it's one of my favorite
because it's not too spicy
just meat flavor just salt and pepper
i love it i can't resist
when i take some meat home i don't need
nothing else especially in the evening
just meet with a melon or
fish or whatever a few slices of bread
couple glasses of wine that's my meal
you don't need nothing else you know you
antonio's right incredible italian hams
and salamis are fantastic in simple
salads
sandwiches or even eaten by themselves
and you don't need much to make an
impression
an amazing selection of delicious meats
from around the world that are great to
use in the kitchen
another simple meaty staple that's
perfect for quick easy suppers with a
difference
are the exotic regional speciality
sausages that have such distinctive
tastes
and are a million miles from the great
british banger
here are four of my favorites that are
definitely worth your money
chorizo from spain these have an
incredibly deep red color
are full of smoky spiced paprika and are
great for stuffing stews and paellas
merguez from north africa made from beef
or mutton
these cook super fast because of the
long and thin shape
and can be used in tagines or served
with couscous
fennel sausages from italy made from
pork and packed with sweet aniseed
flavoured fennel seeds
these are perfect with pasta or as a
topping on a pizza
finally jerk sausages from jamaica full
of blow your head off scotch bonnet
chilis
these are super spicy and great in tangy
casseroles
or simply sauteed with onions and garlic
be adventurous with your sausages
learn about the different flavors and
you'll soon be using them to add extra
flavor with ease
so spend your money wisely and you can
have amazing midweek meals that don't
cost the earth
my next recipe is all about great
flavors and it's as cheap and easy to
make
as it is delicious spicy sausage rice
whatever you're cooking the secret to
making great food is to ensure you're
locking every last
ounce of flavour in that pan and this
spicy sausage rice does exactly that
[Music]
take the spicy sausages and pierce that
skin
because i want all that delicious spicy
sausage meat out of this casing
and you get more flavor from the sausage
when you take them out the casing
sausage is ready turn on the gas bred
onion
less acidic than a big white spanish
onion
and a lot more flavoursome
tablespoon of olive oil a tablespoon
only because i want all that fat coming
out the sausages
to sort of really help flavor the onions
onions in
and the onions go in first because you
can never rush cooking an onion
it's really important to sort of give
them five to six minutes
in the pan so you can really start to
caramelize them
from the out of my pepper slice around
wasting nothing
i want to see that sort of little core
those pips in the center
no fine diced pepper the rice is going
to be cooking for 20 minutes so i want
the veg to sort of
have texture after it's cooked peppers
in
a bit of garlic two nice cloves
just slap down off with a shell
garlic in
now i want to turn up the gas get the
pan nice and hot because the minute that
sausage goes in
everything cools down and you'll end up
boiling the peppers and the onions and
the garlic so
heat up to maximum and then just make a
well
in the center in
now start stirring quickly
this is where you get so much more bang
for your buck out of sausages because
the skins off
and the real flavor of that spicy
italian sausage
is gonna come through what's great about
this recipe is that you can use any type
of sausage
to get the flavor and the heat you want
i've gone for the spicy italian
but it's just as good with merguez or
chorizo
a teaspoon paprika in
give it that really nice smoky flavor
rice in
and we're gonna sort of basically sear
the rice we call it
in the kitchen blasting the rice where
we sort of soaked the rice for 30
seconds
and it takes on all that flavor
next white wine so the wine sort of
deglazes the pan and
washes all that flavor from the bottom
of the pan into the rice
stock in bring it up to the boil turn it
down and let it simmer
[Music]
double stop to rice turn that gas down
and let it simmer for 12 to 15 minutes
and just give it the occasional stir
keep an eye on it now
get ready to finish it slice spring
onions
diced sweet juicy tomatoes and roughly
chop earthy flat leaf parsley
springiness in tomatoes in off with the
gas
really important otherwise everything
becomes overcooked flat leaf parsley
in but look at the volume in that
pan now that is an amazing way to take
spicy italian sausages to a completely
different level
[Music]
beautiful
and prawn balls in aromatic broth
[Music]
for the pork and porn balls in a bowl
add pork mince
then add finely chopped prawns
[Music]
diced ginger and chopped chives
[Music]
season
and roll into ping-pong size balls
[Music]
for the broth eat fresh stock and add
styronesis
oyster sauce soy sauce and sliced ginger
gently simmer fry the pork and prawn
balls in a pan until golden
then transfer to the bubbling broth
[Music]
add handfuls of spinach then serve
topped with finely sliced spring onions
a gorgeous healthy dish
that uses great value ingredients with
amazing results
pork and prawn balls in aromatic broth
ready to eat
in under 20 minutes